the wall street journal reporting
jeffrey epstein may have played a role
in bill and melinda gates divorcing
according to the paper melinda consulted
with divorce lawyers back in 2019 which
is around the time
when reports began to surface that bill
gates had ties to epstein
the couple has not said what led to
their split and bill gates has denied
any wrongdoing with epstein but he did
previously say this
i made a mistake in judgment that i
thought that that
those discussions would lead literally
to billions of dollars going to global
health
uh turned out i that was a bad judge
fox news reached out to bill gates for
comment but we didn't hear back
now greg let me just ask you a simple
question here
if there's a picture of a husband with
epstein is that enough for a wife to ask
for divorce
no you know what's funny it's a it's a
good question because
we're living in a time where now any
picture
is is like could be it could be used
against you and if you're a celebrity
especially as
a big one like me um i am in a lot of
like
i i sign a lot of books i meet a lot of
fans you never know
epstein could have been in line to get
my book the joy of hate which by the way
you should order
and you know you get a picture taken
with him and all of a sudden it's like
ah gut felt scene with
jeffrey epstein but i have a theory on
this i don't know
anything about this at all and that's
not going to stop me
i wonder i think the more probable the
more probable reality is that this is a
nasty divorce
and a good lawyer a great lawyer is
especially
nasty and will use everything possible
in your toolkit
to tar and feather the other spouse and
it always astounds me
in divorces big name divorces how people
can accuse each other of the very worst
thing
as part of the negotiation and then when
it's all over
everybody's like ah no it really didn't
happen we're all it's all everything's
fine
i tried i mean you he hit me she hit me
he drove the kids drunk and then
all that stuff just goes away when they
sign on the dotted line
i have a feeling that this is there's
something prob i mean she is so pissed
off at him for something could be the
new
the naked swim parties i don't know
what i didn't hear
in the post today i only went to three
of them all right and there are no
pictures
all right so dana so
let's let's just do a little journalism
who do you think is the source for that
wall street journal
article is it melinda gates's lawyers is
it bill gates's lawyers
uh you know it's 130 billion dollars at
stake
i don't know i mean it could be jeffrey
epstein from the grave i have no idea
who it is
um i do know that um in her language she
says that the marriage
was irretrievably broken yes so that
means
something was bad yes i don't know what
it is
but for to spend that much time together
in a lifetime
to have those children to have this
effort the company that you built and
the philanthropy that you built and then
to say that it is irretrievably broken
we may never know actually what what
really happened
um and you know obviously i i hope for
their for their sakes that they can get
some privacy but
this story obviously would raise a lot
of eyebrows so they say
yeah so katie we do know that uh gates
flew with epstein down to florida
in 2013 that jet obviously a lot of talk
but we don't have any evidence that he's
done anything immoral right
with uh jeffrey epstein or in other
situations
yeah with anybody yeah with anybody
well look look i think this is revenge
uh
from melinda for his living girlfriend
that he got to go visit
once a year once a month or whatever
that weird arrangement was
throughout the course of their marriage
i'm with greg i don't think this is an
amicable divor
amicable divorce i think this is going
to get even nastier when you're starting
out with the epstein card i don't know
what the connection was there
but the news that i'm interested in
today is
benefer being back which ben affleck and
jennifer lopez are allegedly dating
again
i mean that's a big deal guys that's new
news they're talking about it in the
green room
spotted in montana
yeah uh jessie is it possible jesse that
melinda and bill
married a long time and just fell out of
love
that's possible although i'm with
gutfeld this was a fastball from her
legal team and said
we're ready to play dirty and it's going
to go the way i want it to go
or maybe there was some sort of
relationship between gates and epson
that we don't know about that really
precipitated it
i don't know but i'm with greg i'm just
going to speculate and here's my
speculation
i think that epstein was looking for a
whale
remember he had les wexner's money the
victoria's secret billionaire and he
managed his money and helped to move
money around for the irs
he was looking for the next whale and
who's bigger whale
than the richest guy in the world at the
time than
gates and i know that gates actually
sent an email after they met
that's been published that says you know
this guy is interesting
very intriguing not necessarily how i
would live my life
but you know what that's who he is and i
think that's kind of an acknowledgement
that he was aware
of something that epstein was involved
in although we don't know
to the extent all right
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else